[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance there have been countless
crazy and/or impeachable things done by
Donald Trump or in his name since the
inauguration these are just the top 50
here they are as fast as I can blow
through them January 20th pounds into
the White House leaving the first lady's
standing alone by the car insists at an
inaugural ball that it stopped raining
as he started to give his inaugural
address when in fact it started raining
as he started to speak January 21st goes
to speak at the CIA memorial wall
reportedly bringing his own staff with
him to applaud him claims he holds the
record for the most time magazine covers
he actually has 11 Richard Nixon 55
claims that the crowd at his
inauguration extended to the Washington
Monument has his press secretary who is
a Melissa McCarthy character shout a lie
to the reporters quote this was the
largest audience to ever witness an
inauguration period January 22nd implies
none of the women's March participants
had voted after repeatedly stating he
would release his tax returns after an
audit was complete Kellyanne Conway says
quote he's not going to release his tax
returns January 23rd tells congressional
leaders he would have one popular vote
if it had not been for three to five
million illegal votes January 24th
tweets a panoramic photo of the
inauguration as evidence of his crowd
size claims doesn't notice photo is
mistakenly dated January 21st the day
after his inauguration claims carnage in
Chicago threatens to send in quote the
feds without ever saying that he means
the military or Eliot Ness and his
Untouchables January 25th makes up story
about two people being murdered during
Obama's Chicago farewell speech
threatens to cut off federal funds to
sanctuary cities demands investigation
into non-existent voter fraud
specifically voters registered in more
than one state doesn't seem to notice
that among voters registered in more
than one state are Steve Bannon Sean
Spicer Steve minuchin son-in-law Jared
Kushner and his own daughter Tiffany
sites Pew Research data too
poor his voter fraud claims the author
of the report refutes the voter fraud
claims then claims pew researcher is
grumbling and suppressing the truth
tells interviewer about imaginary three
to five million fraudulent votes quote
if you look at it they all voted for
Hillary they all voted for Hillary they
didn't vote for me I don't believe I got
one okay
these are people that voted for Hillary
Clinton ignores logic that his
conspiracy theory thus requires that
Democrats planted 5 million illegal
voters around the country but forgot to
put any of them in the states where just
77,000 votes cost Clinton the election
January 26 reported to a personally
pressured United States Park Service to
support his inauguration crowd
exaggeration after campaigning against
Clinton for slovenly handling of
classified data and private email is
reported to have tied the POTUS Twitter
account to private email and to be using
only one-step security and to be
tweeting from what appears to be a
five-year-old non secure phone January
27th sites voting fraud expert who
claims three million illegal votes but
who has never produced any of the
evidence he has repeatedly promised
issues statement commemorating
international Holocaust Remembrance Day
that does not include the words Jew
Judaism or Jewish Institute's a refugee
ban on Muslim nations on a day that
recalls how America turned its back on
refugees from Nazi Germany January 28
Muslim ban is so hastily introduced no
one knows how it applies to those with
green cards and border and customs
agents are left guessing what to do next
in phone call with Prime Minister of
Australia becomes angered about
agreed-upon refugee resettlement deal
reportedly hangs up on Prime Minister
January 29th falsely claims Muslim ban
is just an offshoot of the re-evaluation
of immigrant vetting once ordered by
Obama this was only in Iraq dismisses
anti ban statement by senators Graham
and McCain by calling them quote former
presidential candidates says nothing as
purported white supremacist Trump fan
allegedly opened fire at a Quebec
city mosque killing six injuring five
January thirtieth claims weekend Airport
chaos pose not to his Muslim and Refugee
ban but to Delta computer problems and
the quote fake tears of Senator Schumer
ignoring the tumors great-grandmother
and seven her nine siblings were
murdered by the Nazis after they were
unable to become refugees January 31st
among those confirming they were
detained in a u.s. airport during Muslim
ban crisis because he once visited Iran
the former Prime Minister of Norway
February 1st commemorates started Black
History Month by seemingly implying he
does not realize Frederick Douglas has
been dead since 1895 then complains
about CNN vice president pence
commemorates start of Black History
Month by tweeting tribute to Abraham
Lincoln White House does not issue read
out a weekend phone call between Trump
and Vladimir Putin reportedly because
White House switched off the recorder at
axe Australian Refugee deal calling the
twelve hundred and fifty refugees quote
thousands of illegal immigrants revealed
by personal position to be taking doses
of the drug propecia to promote hair
growth possible side effects include
dizziness weakness feeling like you
might pass out and quote abnormal
ejaculation February second that
National Prayer Breakfast asked for
prayers for Arnold Schwarzenegger TV
ratings and also at prayer breakfast in
front of religious leaders from 70
countries says quote the hell with it
adjust sanctions against the sales of
cybersecurity materials to the Russian
FSB the same spy agency accused of
blackmailing him administration claims
yemen raid was authorized by Obama to
Obama administration national security
advisers publicly state this is not true
advisor propaganda Barbie
Kellyanne Conway complains that media
has ignored one of the justifications
for the Muslim ban namely the
bowling-green massacre there was no
Bowling Green massacre
Conway claims she misspoke cosmopolitan
and TMZ will later report she had
already cited the same
and a fictional massacre in interviews
with them tweets that Iran has been
quote formally put on notice even though
the phrase means nothing diplomatically
or militarily places on the national
security staff a man who helped add the
infamous 16 words to george w bush's
2003 State of the Union address
February 3rd tweets about a quote new
radical Islamic terrorist with a knife
at the Louvre museum in Paris the attack
was at the Louvre mall there was one
minor injury the alleged perpetrator is
Egyptian and would not have been
prevented from entering the u.s. by the
Trump ban Trump still has not mentioned
the Quebec mosque attack the Pentagon
posts terrorist video supposedly
obtained during that Yemen raid to prove
the raid was worth it administration
pulls down that terrorist video when it
turns out that terrorist video has been
on the internet since 2007
February 4th in clip revealed in advance
of the Superbowl interview says he
respects Vladimir Putin interviewer says
quote but he's a killer though Putin's a
killer Trump replies there are a lot of
killers we've got a lot of killers what
you think our country's so innocent
pressed he implies those killers could
include those involved in the war in
Iraq deputy editor of Wall Street
Journal editorial page then tweets never
in history has a president slandered his
country like this and he's goddamned
right February 5th finishes two day long
siege of Twitter attacks against the
Washington State judge who ruled against
the Muslim ban writing possible
terrorism quote if something happens
blame him and court system is reported
to have signed the executive order
placing Steve Madden on the National
Security Council without fully reading
it first Super Bowl interviewer now
presses him for data to support illegal
voting claims and he replies forget that
forget all that and that implies
registration rolls prove him right
suggesting he doesn't realize that not
everybody who is registered votes
February 6 after one poll showing his
first approval rating at a record low 40
percent and a CBS poll showing his
Muslim ban imposed by 51 to 45 percent
and a CNN poll showing it rejected 53 to
47% tweets right out of George Orwell
any negative polls are fake news and
deliberately lies to officers and troops
at US Central Command that the media
does not want to report terrorist
attacks quote they have their reasons
and you understand that in any other
context business or country Trump's
supporters would now be organizing his
removal from authority even if it were
only for his own good
get him out of here resist peace